[Music]
all right let's go to hamilton
new jersey what's up lynn how are we
doing
hi dr john it's such an honor to speak
to you thanks so much for taking the
call it's an honor for me i i'm grateful
that you called what's up
so
um me and my husband have been married
for 23 years
and we run a home-based business where
we work together on the daily
it's been super successful
my husband's an awesome entrepreneur he
does an amazing job
you know
responding to challenges adapting to
growth it's it's been
a huge success we have substantial
savings
we live debt free we have a paid off
home
my challenges is even with all this
success that we've had
he still feels like he's in survival
mode
if our business isn't growing
and we're working working working
and
i feel like we're not on the same page
anymore as in regard to
work life
balance
okay
you know pressure from the business
kind of just sucks the fun out of our
life is causing me to get defensive and
it's affecting how we enjoy each other
and just live our daily life gotcha
gotcha
um
so what do you want to do
well
um
i love the business i love that we have
flexibility i love um you know the
day-to-day work
i personally would like to scale back
travel a little bit more
but um again he feels like he's in this
survival mode
which to me is not the case right
uh it's pretty common and you you know
this i mean you live it um
that
people can turn their vocation their
business their job into
who they are
and that sentiment you know if you're
not growing you're dying
right whatever that is yeah um that that
can become a personal identity
if i'm not making more money than i made
last quarter that i i me i am failing
and if i'm failing i have nothing
and so i've got to do whatever i can do
to make sure this this proxy this thing
that i have outsourced my identity to
this business
and by the way business has a dollar
amount right it's got a score card and
so i i just get a real time
you can't find out if you did a good job
with your kids right until a teacher
tells you or until they marry well or
whatever
your business tells you every day if
you're failing or if you're winning
right all that to say is this um i don't
think this is a business question at all
i think this is a life question
and i
just listen to you talk i i think you
like your life that this business
affords you more than the business is
that fair
very 100 spot on okay
um
and my guess is your husband very
similar he may not love the business as
much as the business gives him has
propped him up for a long long time
and
um at some point
that it'll kill you
right or you'll die of natural causes i
think here's the ultimate question
uh who do we want to become now
and
that you usually just takes has couples
sitting down saying okay we are
50 we are 65 what are what have we done
all of this for if not to enjoy it and
not to go live our lives
and so the question is who are we going
to be i would love to see you this is
just me throwing a grenade in your home
um for fun and also i'm being kind of
serious i would love to see you turn in
like a six weeks notice
[Music]
i'm resigning okay
i'm not going to work here anymore
because i want to go enjoy my life and i
would love for you to come with me
and i would love for you to go on dates
with me and go hiking and whatever
things y'all want to do go salsa dance
or whatever the thing is
i would love for you to do that with me
and you can choose to value
grinding and killing and crushing it
more than you value doing those things
with me but i'm gonna go do them
so when i just said that
your voice tone
changed why
i agree with you
i thought it would scare me when you
first were saying it but i i i'm kind of
into it i'm kind of digging it just
resign
you work for yourself you can quit
yeah and i'm saying it was smile on my
face
is that does that sound freeing
it sounds amazing
okay here's here's the big question most
of the times couples get into
discussions that turn into debates that
turn into fights
and it's about money
our business
it's about um
well who's gonna that kind of stuff this
isn't that conversation
this conversation is honey we have
enough
i want a different kind of life now
or i want a life that looks like xy or z
and then what kind of work or business
can we put into that life that supports
it but that the world doesn't revolve
around that anymore and for those
listening who are younger there are
seasons when you're 20 and you're 30
when your life has to revolve around
you you've got to get yourself in a
position to be st for stability right
that's every job throughout all of
history
and now there's a big thing for 20 year
olds that are quitting
and like i'm just gonna
um
i don't know i'm just gonna get a
minimum wage job because i'm gonna live
and love my life and that just means i'm
gonna play video games or i'm gonna go
hiking or whatever and i think that's a
terrible mistake
but you are the opposite of that y'all
put all the work and time in
and here you are right how old are you
uh he just turned 50 i'm 52. so we've
put
years of sacrifice in
and you're 10 years ahead of the curve
if not 20 years right
i'd like to think so yeah okay could you
could you hire somebody to run this
business
that would provide you all with some
money and some purpose and he's still a
part of it but also some flexibility or
is it really
built around him and you it
it's i think it's built around him
because we have
made it built around him ah you're so
smart i love it i love it you know if
that makes sense
that's a really nice way to say i'm
married to somebody with a sizable ego
and
it's worked for us so far
a lot of control issues
and and that's another thing we we
are challenged with too is
sometimes
you know things aren't done perfectly or
aren't done exactly the way so i think
that would be a challenge in
it's it's not being done the way he
would do it right so i'll just do it
myself oh and it's got my name on it so
i'm it the buck stops with me all those
noble ideas that have become quotes over
time
become a way of living and then there's
a spouse and there's a kid and then
there's a person inside of him that's
going
yeah what about life though right yep so
it's both hand
yeah it's both in so here's something my
wife did for me i think i've mentioned
on the show um a little bit um so i've
worked in non-profits my whole career
i've been in education forever working
at universities and in public schools
and so coming to this job
was the
it was like somebody opened the
floodgates for me
where
i was on call for for for 365 24 7 for
almost 20 years and if i went to the
hospital four nights a week to be with
students and i got up at 2 a.m to deal
with drunk students three nights a week
my paycheck stayed the same
and if i
built a new residence hall or recruited
a thousand new students my paycheck
stayed the same this is the first time
it's like man
you write another book then you get more
money and if you get on the road and go
speak at more places and go do more
consulting you you make more right so
it has
i feel like i have had some tethers just
clipped and i'm running as fast as i can
and it was this past christmas break
that my wife sat down and said john we
have enough
you i
i need you
and that was really hard for me to hear
and she was right and she said your kids
need you
and from this point forward any time you
think you're gonna go quote-unquote make
some more money for us
i need you to hear
me say that's not true it's a lie that
you're telling yourself
huh and it too that like cut me i was
like
you know what i mean
yeah the same as she said we don't need
any more deep freezers like we're good
all right so same thing right and so we
don't need more guitars or guns or
anything like that so there was a wisdom
there though that i had to look in the
mirror and say i'm running and running
and running and i'm telling myself it's
for these other people but it's for me
yeah it's for me and it's fine that it's
for me that's good but it's coming at a
cost of exactly that was hard
but i would love to see you put in your
six week notice and see what see what
happens how do you think how do you
think he'll respond to that
i'm just curious
i i think it would be
a wake-up call okay
and um you know i'm sure it would lead
us to the bigger discussion that needs
to happen
but i i kind of like the shock factor of
it
don't get me in trouble okay here's if
i'm you here's how i would do this and
again every marriage is different i
would set up a nice dinner we'd go
somewhere we'd not wait until there's
like already uh we're already fighting
about something else and it would be
something planned i have an announcement
to make i would also
do and i know you've fantasized about
this but be concrete about it what would
you do instead because you can't do
nothing right you got to have a purpose
you've got to have are we going to go
visit people are we going to get an rv
are we going to work from
like what are we going to do just not
nothing right yeah yep
okay let me know how that goes and uh if
you want to call about uh
please don't blow things up actually you
know what it's your life you can do it
every week do whatever you want to
i love it and by the way
this is
i feel like i need to say this on behalf
of people like me and your husband
he's doing this because he loves you a
lot right
a hundred percent understood and i
i don't want to feel or
come across as ungrateful
because
you know we are where we are because of
it
but
something's got to give that's right i
think there's a way to do it not where
you're ungrateful where you are super
grateful yes like you've given us 30
years of your life
yeah and now we want you to take your
life back
yep
i love it and i quit
i'd be so good oh man oh man you're
awesome lynn thank you so much for that
call
um yeah let me know how that one goes i
can't wait to hear it